I challenge your leader to personal
combat
[Applause]
[Music]
have you got the side of the bar maybe
they can hit that
study
[Music]
know why
[Music]
it's my sister
hello brother
shall we talk shall I address you as
Megan let's keep it simple you otherwise
Drago
wise I expected you to have the same
opinion of Dragons as your brother does
[Applause]
[Music]
Pizza mercy sister
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
which way
[Music]
[Applause]
you're welcome
they always forget you look forward to
take me down you see the dragon shape in
the stars Draco the eternal resting
ground for dragons who are worthy
don't worry do you want in a place your
grandfather surveyed the kingdom from
the air let me give you a ride it's
faster we can use the time to better
understand the bond between us
I'll take my chance on the crime thanks
when you were born you inherited a gift
a dragon Hart's power the Justice miner
with the same this run together
dragon horns battle for the heart fire
or blu-ray June 30
you